pro-democracy activists say they fear
the end of Hong Kong after China
announced plans to enforce new national
security laws in the semi-autonomous
region the clamp down is aimed at
curbing protests which have brought
violent demonstrations to the territory
over the past year
well I'm joined now by the
secretary-general of the pro-democracy
party de meses Tok Joshua Wong who's
also a prominent activist Joshua really
appreciate you talking to a sermon this
morning firstly what could a change in
law mean for activists such as yourself
agent announced to bypassed the
Legislative Council in Hong Kong and
imposed the controversial bill that were
eroding the freedom of Hong Kong which
named as the national security law which
just result in hong kong turn from one
country to system to a one country one
system hong kong back in 2003 tries to
in that sedition law some half a million
people turned up onto the streets what
should we expect in 2020 in 2003 beijing
suggested impose the law and is still at
least go through the legislation process
in hong kong local level but right now
beijing just announced that the national
people congress will bypass and override
the legal system and also the
legislature in hong kong and imposed
what they want and to targeted dissident
in the previous day
No Boundaries pyrene Alicia Obama just
exists in China but now in upcoming
future might exist in Hong Kong so how
can we prepare for the fight and
mobilize more people even than 2019
that's the challenge that Hong Kong is
face
Beijing says this is to make sure that
national security is protected I mean
how concerned are you that it's going to
stop you carrying out the ability to
demonstrate an ability that am you in
Hong Kong on the territory halt oh dear
that's not the national security law we
would describe it as kind of security
law for the interests of communist
regime and the most important issue is
this national security law it lost it
detail regulation mentioned it might
targeted any activist or politician that
engage in any kind of international
efficacy which means that if young
activists
participate in congressional hearing met
with MPs in UK they might also been
targeted and also face any kind of
political prosecution that we never
imagined in a previous day but Hong Kong
is no city we must let our voice being
heard
well what so what do you think is likely
to happen now I mean what do you think
Beijing's response will be if there are
a widespread protests across the
territory I believe we can mobilize more
than million Hong Kong tech back to the
street before or after the anniversary
of Tiananmen Square massacre absolutely
it will at Beijing you know that Hong
Kong never cut out of Beijing even under
the chilling effect generated by them do
you think it will make a difference I
mean Beijing hasn't budged from his
position in the past last year more than
few millions Hong Kong talked to the
street result in the controversial
extradition bill we've drawed it by
Beijing and Beijing compromise to Hong
Kong is and we believe how the national
security law pink eye really imposed it
from Beijing to Hong Kong without any
procedural justice or imbalance we just
proved that it will trigger another
another trend of Hong Kong is get her on
straight again in the summer so what do
you make claims by and Beijing's and
officials in China who say that people
like you activists them like yourself
despite being and parts of the political
and party are troublemakers
you're there to cause disruption in the
territory we are just asking for free
election if if other international
cities just like New York or London they
can let the resident to elect the mayor
so why can't Hong Kong the only reason
behind is Beijing broke the promise of
the sino-british joint declaration and
impose the national security law
turn hong kong to be one country one
system and even until this moment no one
could ensure a guarantee if any Hong
Kong is might be extra die or being bred
being ranked to China to face the trial
without any transparency and any kind of
go principal so the tremendous change
lies ahead we must keep on the fights in
Hong Kong and also encourage more world
leaders and also a politician around the
world to stem of Hong Kong to confront a
crackdown from the National people
Congress in Beijing you mentioned world
leaders there I'm Joshua just looking to
what the USM State Department has said
off the back of their so any effort to
impose national security legislation
that does not reflect the will of the
people of Hong Kong will be highly
disabled izing and would be met with
strong condemnation from the
international community so with that in
mind is that for you with confidence
no matter global menisci act in European
country or Hong Kong human rights and
democracy acts in the United States we
also encourage the world to stem of Hong
Kong and actions speak louder than words
it's time to enhance and impose the
sanction mechanism and let baking to
realize that they can't ignore the
universal value that we all believe in
especially when now the number of
arrested activists in Hong Kong since
last summer are already more than the
number of police the number of prisoners
now being basically a lot of imprison
the chilling effect generated by Beijing
is far from any run imagination 23 years
ago before the transfer of sovereignty
but that but now it's also a critical
timing to urge the world to stem of Hong
Kong and we also look forward for the UK
Foreign Ministry to respond to the
crisis happening in Hong Kong